[Music]
[Music]
hey
everybody it's sunday yeah hopefully you
guys didn't miss us too much last night
yeah we went out last night yeah we had
a good time had a good time it was kind
of dead there wasn't a lot of people out
well there was a lot of people in
downtown sanford yeah but there wasn't a
lot of people at that bar
we actually hadn't been to we went to
our friend uh
our friend big tom's bar that he owns
mannequins which is like a horror themed
bar and uh we hadn't been there
[ __ ] it seems like we were just there a
few months ago but then
um i he had kept talking about he was
gonna buy the building next door and he
was gonna knock the wall out like to
make a bigger
uh dance floor and he did it and
because i went in there i'm like holy
crap look at this it's like sitting
right inside the youtube
yeah so he must have just done that in
the last couple of months because we
were just there a few months ago and it
wasn't like that yeah look cool
yeah it looks really good and like i
said that back uh that back patio looks
fantastic
that's massive he's got all he's got a
hookah thing back there and he's got
a whole other bar and couches and
everything and we and we got to eat at
chantals again
yeah got some soul food yeah like i got
some she had she got that damn
fish and chips it was good i probably
got that damn that was delicious yeah
yeah you got jerk chicken didn't you
yeah it was good yeah that's a cool
place i like it
but yeah so uh so we had a good time
once i'm tired not hungover nothing but
you know um before oh before we do the
movie review i want to shout out
i already said can a message about this
but you remember on that one show i was
saying i really liked cashew butter
ken sent me two jars of this
delicious premium like organic cashew
butter
and i wanted to like thank him very much
for that like this there's another jar
but i already opened that one and like
was scarfing it on some toast so that's
it's in the fridge
but yeah so it's really really good uh
you know when i haven't had any for a
long time so it's
it's really nice so i just thought i
would shout it out on the show
now we were going to uh
we need to review the coming to america
sequel but we haven't
had a chance to watch it yet we'll
probably watch it tonight i imagine
and then we can do the matinee on it
tomorrow so this is a movie that we saw
a couple of days ago this movie is
called
lucky now it came out back in 2020
like it did all the horror festivals and
stuff like that but shutter just added
it like a few days ago i think they
added it like on thursday or whatever
because i think that's when i watched it
now this movie was written by
and stars bria grant who was also in
that other movie after midnight that we
talked about
last week i think it was she might have
co-written that one too
i think she also did 12 hour shift which
is another one that people have been
recommending so i might get around to
seeing that one as well
um but yeah so this was directed by
natasha
kermani and it's okay
i really really liked this movie you
liked it too right yeah it was good yeah
i thought it was good
um it's gonna be i think it's gonna be
one of those movies that
it might be a little bit divisive just
but it's gonna be really really hard to
talk about without spoiling it
but okay so here's the setup it's kind
of like
a slasher but not
it's kind of like a slasher mixed with
groundhog day kind of
or happy death day but not as funny as
that it does have some satirical or like
funny elements to it but it's not
a comedy i don't think it's kind of like
a horror thriller dude keeps attacking
her she kills him
but he vanishes and comes back yeah
so the setup is the bria grant plays
may and she is a successful
self-help author um but she's been kind
of going through some [ __ ] like i guess
her last book was kind of a big thing
and
um it's i think it was called go it
alone which is
you know kind of uh relevant to the plot
um but you know the publisher is like
not real excited about
her next book because maybe sales have
been going down or whatever so and she
has like some other [ __ ] going on
that you kind of find out about like
over the course of the thing
but very very early in the movie she's
she hears something downstairs in her
house
and she looks out the window and there's
a dude like out in the [ __ ]
uh yard like looking in the window and
she's wigging out like she goes up and
tells her husband she's like um
hey there's a man and then a man in the
yard and then
they hear a window breaking and her
husband is just so this is
it's such a great scene and i think they
put it in the trailer even
but um he's just kind of like very
casual and he's just like oh yeah that's
the dude that shows up every night and
tries to kill us
we i guess we better get our weapons
like he gets again it's a golf club and
[ __ ] like that
so basically what this is is
this dude literally comes back every
night
and tries to kill her because at one
point her and her husband like have a
fight and he
leaves like for a few days so she's
there by herself so the guy just keeps
coming back
and so she has to kind of um fight him
now that's kind of all i can say about
the movie without spoiling it like i
said it's very
it has a little bit of a twilight zony
kind of thing
in the same way that the movie after
midnight which she was also in
had kind of like a metaphorical aspect
where like the monster was kind of like
a metaphor even though it was a real
monster but it was like a metaphor too
um the man in this one like the the
stalker
he is also a metaphor for some [ __ ] but
the thing that's cool about it is that
it's obviously a metaphorical story
but it kind of leaves it open-ended as
to what
the man represents you know what i mean
that's that's what all
that's how i'll say it um some people
might get frustrated because they kind
of
leave it ambiguous or as i said they
leave it open-ended like they
you you know there are several different
interpretations that you could take away
from it i guess
but it kind of leaves it up to you as to
what you think
the situation is or you know what you
think that it represents
but so you know so i can see like some
people i've seen
uh real mixed reviews of it like some
people really really seem to dig it a
lot and then some people were just like
man they didn't like it because it was
just
because they didn't like that it was
left too open-ended or they thought it
was
the metaphor was too heavy-handed or
something like that but i really really
liked it i really
the acting was really good um it had
like some funny like some dark humor
in it but it wasn't like overtly comedic
uh the cinematography was kind of cool
it's almost kind of like
because it's almost kind of like it
started out kind of normal but then as
[ __ ] started getting like more and more
surreal like the cinematography got like
more surreal a little bit like with all
the like weird blue and red light and
everything
but yeah i had like a really good score
cool [ __ ]
uh you know cool [ __ ] flick and i
guess like i said the the woman that was
in it bria grant
who i had remembered i think i said this
on the after midnight review i
remembered her from
dexter but she's been in a bunch of
other things too um
i think she said in an interview that
she got the idea for this movie
when she either had a stalker or was or
somebody broke into her house and
attacked her or something like that and
her having to deal with
uh you know the police and having to
deal with people not
believing her or not something like that
so that's kind of where she got the i
the germ of the idea for this but yeah
it's like i really really liked it a lot
um shutter just added on thursday
uh i think it's on shutter in the uk
and in australia as well because i did
see like an australian reviewer that i
like spooky astronauts
and she's australian and she saw it on
shutter over there um and i think i saw
a british guy that had
seen it too so it's on shutter pretty
much all over the english-speaking world
if you want to watch it like i said it's
very clearly metaphorical it's very
um so don't go into it expecting a
comedy and don't go into it expecting a
slasher movie
it does have some violence it is kind of
bloody but
it's not i don't know it's it's kind of
hard to describe
you know like i said it's kind of a
slasher but it's also
got like a weird psychological twist to
it and it has like it's sort of dream
like or
surreal i guess but yeah so
good flick that's all i got to say about
it like i said i don't want to spoil it
too much but
that's pretty much the setup and i think
the setup for it
you know is in the trailer they say this
is the guy that turns up every night and
tries to kill us
or tries to kill you and i liked it i
thought i thought it was uh
well directed it was a good quality
movie it wasn't exactly like
my type of movie you know it wasn't like
really my taste it's not something i'd
seek out
but you know i i you know i appreciate
it for what it was
it was pretty enjoyable i thought
because i really liked
i think the main thing that i liked
about it was her reaction to the
situation
i gotta say it's not it's not a chick
flick but it i think the topic and just
the way it was told was kind of appeal
more to women
i definitely think that as well and i'm
not saying that dudes wouldn't like it
because you know i've seen a lot of male
reviewers that liked it as well
yeah but i think women will take more
away from it
yeah than a guy than a guy would because
i think they can relate to it better and
they can relate to her character better
yeah there's a female perspective to it
yeah well it's a female director it's a
female writer
um so obviously which that's the way
he's gonna go i guess yeah yeah well you
know
we we gotta we got ideas for [ __ ] too
well no i'm just saying nothing bad
about it
yeah that's what i'm saying right um
let's see
uh what what are they talking about
so our yeah tila said she saw coming to
america on friday very disappointing see
everybody keep saying that's what i'm
kind of hearing and it's like i'm really
bummed out we're gonna watch it tonight
and uh we'll give you our thoughts about
it tomorrow but i try not to like i said
you know read
[ __ ] about movies before i see them
because i like to approach them
you know on my own terms but
i can't help like when i'm scrolling
through like you know some blogs or
something like that i can see a headline
and people are like meh
i subscribe to world class bullshitters
uh it's
it's a youtube channel it's really good
and those guys
usually they kind of call it they're
they they're a good predictor whether or
not i'm gonna like it
you know and they they were real excited
to see it
and they came back and go man it's just
kind of a rehash of the first one it's
just
you know it's just like a remake of the
first one they they were disappointed
with yeah see that's kind of what i
heard too yeah they just that it had
like essentially the same story
they were like on the back of dolomite
you know what i mean dolomite is my name
that
they thought that they were really gonna
get it man what if you had a great movie
that was
i guess there's i i don't know i just
got to reserve judgment on it
yeah because i haven't seen it yeah
we're going to watch this kind of
disappointed it probably is
and like i said that's that's pretty
much universally what i'm hearing
um which like i said that bums me out
yeah
but i don't know we'll see we're gonna
we're gonna watch it in a few hours yeah
and uh we'll see how it goes and we'll
talk about it tomorrow
yeah but now i'm kind of like yeah like
oh man
i know i was like super pumped for it
and now i'm just kind of like oh man
yeah that's the bummer all right
yeah mango said sadly this is no
dolomite i mean
dolomite is my name was such a [ __ ]
great movie that's
gonna be like a hard hard thing to
follow up on oh well
um all right so i guess this has been a
little bit kind of short today but we're
really really sleepy yeah i mean i slept
in this morning but
for some reason i'm still waiting yeah
he's like oh i found an energy drink in
the refrigerator
yeah they don't give me any [ __ ]
energy though i think that's [ __ ] i
think that's a damn
i drink them and i don't feel any
different well it's just kind of like
everybody says they have coffee and it
wakes them up i never really
i never feel awake after drinking coffee
sometimes it makes me sleepier sometimes
it doesn't do anything
the only time i've ever felt effects
from
caffeine was when i drank a [ __ ]
load and i'm talking a shitload like two
or three big
like venti starbucks size
then okay yeah then my eyeballs started
to vibrate but if it's just like one or
two cups
i don't feel [ __ ] doesn't wake me up you
know
um but yeah so like i said this one's
kind of short but
if if you're into if that you know the
movie lucky sounds like something that
you would like i really liked it tom
liked
it uh it's on shutter at the moment and
uh we'll be talking about
coming to america coming to america too
tomorrow because we're gonna watch it in
a couple of hours
and uh yeah we've only been on for like
15 minutes or something like that but
now i'm like super paranoid shit's gonna
crash because of all the [ __ ]
but yeah so um we'll uh probably
yeah y'all partied hard last night yeah
i mean we drank a lot and
you know got some good food and sauce
a few people there's a bunch of
strangers there we don't spend a lot of
time in downtown sanford so it's like we
don't have
it's not like going to eye bar where we
know everybody you know what i'm saying
yeah it's just kind of like a bunch of
random people and then like some people
just know
owners yeah pretty much
[Laughter]
all right but yeah uh we'll be back
tomorrow uh
thanks everybody for dropping by for
this brief little
sunday movie review and we'll see